so viele wie noch nie fast 24.000
deutsche sind neu mit corona infiziert
das lka warnt vor lockerungen an
weihnachten eine lösung in sicht im
haushaltsstreit mit ungarn und polen
steht die eu kurz vor einem durchbruch
und klar gegen einen giganten den us
kartellbehörde und mehr als 40
bundesstaaten wollen die marktmacht von
facebook gerechnet
[Musik]
die nachrichten nicht da das heute mit
christian sievers guten abend hinein an
diesem 10
dezember wir gucken auf diesen
nachrichten tag und katja stresow hat
den sport heute im blick sehr gern sogar
schon genannt es ist ein neuer
höchststand heute bei der zahl der
gemeldeten corona infektionen in
deutschland
obwohl es ja seit wochen einen
teilweisen shutdown gibt geht die zahl
nicht nur nicht runter
sie steigt jetzt sogar wieder woran
liegt das ist die zunehmend drängend und
einigermaßen ratlos gestellte frage
der chef des robert koch instituts sieht
einer zitat gewisse ermüdung sich an die
schutzmaßnahmen zu halten
er sagt auch das virus zirkuliere
zunehmend in risikogruppen ein großteil
der korona toten in deutschland sei 80
jahre alt und älter
das robert koch institut meldet 23 1679
neue fälle innerhalb von 24 stunden das
sind 1633 mehr als vor einer woche
und es kamen 4 140 todesfälle in
verbindung mit dem virus dazu
die lage könne schnell kippen sagt
institutschef lothar wieler und warnt
davor dass die zahlen exponentiell
steigen könnten
mehr von anselm stern so sehen sie aus
diese dezember abende in deutschland wie
hier bayerische corona hotspots
ausgangssperre kontrolliert von der
polizei das vorweihnachtliche
beisammensein soll nicht sein virus
verbreitung eindämmen das ziel doch da
gäbe es schlechte nachrichten sagt heute
der chef des robert koch instituts die
lage ist nach wie vor sehr ernst sie hat
sich seit letzter woche tatsächlich
sogar verschlechtert die fallzahlen
befinden sich ja seit wochen auf einem
hohen plateau aktuell sehen wir sogar
wieder einen anstieg der fallzahlen klar
erkennbar bei den täglichen
neuinfektionen im 7 tagesschnitt seit
mitte november recht stabil bei etwa
18.000 jetzt steigen sie wieder und das
nach wochen mit strengeren antivirus
maßnahmen wie kann das sein ein grund
von vielen möglichen noch immer zu viele
kontakte im ganzen land wir sehen
dass der anteil der kontakt reduktion
einfach nicht ausreicht willkommen
bislang auf eine kontakt reduktion auf
etwa führt und etwa 40
und wir sind der festen meinung dass für
einen kontakt reduktion brauchen die
über 60 prozent liegt und so kommen noch
härtere einschnitte an der plan
spätestens ab weihnachten vielleicht
schon kurz davor sollen außer
supermärkten alle geschäfte dicht machen
auch die schulen bis weit in den januar
ich glaube diese zweieinhalb drei wochen
ermöglichen uns ganz viel an gesundheits
und infektionsschutz nicht unterstützte
den vorschlag dass wir deutschlandweit
einen stärkeren shutdown brauchen wenn
wir nicht schnell und frühzeitig handeln
wer dann werden wir auch anfang januar
noch ein infektionsgeschehen haben was
uns keine weiteren lockerungsschritte
möglich macht keine lockerungen
einschränkungen verschärfen das ist die
tonlage bei vielen die entscheiden
müssen
genau zwei wochen vor weihnachten wartet
das land auf den nächsten virus gipfel
von bund und ländern auf die nächste
phase im kampf gegen die krise das
stichwort für theo koll den wir auch
heute abend meter zu holen
theo wir reden seit tagen an dieser
stelle darüber wie die reaktion aus der
politik aussehen könnte und auch wenn
wir klarheit bekommen gibt es denn da
heute neues
der kanzleramtsminister hat heute den
ganzen tag mit den bundesländern
telefoniert und verhandelt noch immer
sind weder die maßnahmen noch die form
neuer beschlüsse entschieden die meisten
der von uns heute befragten gehen weiter
davon aus ihren dritten advent mit dem
thema verbringen zu dürfen kern
streitpunkte sind kommt es zu
schließungen schon vor weihnachten wie
einheitlich soll das vorgehen seien und
wer zahlt wem die ausfälle wir reden
immerhin vom umsatzstärksten monat für
viele geschäfte das nach weihnachten bis
weit in den januar vieles dicht gemacht
wird daran zweifelt hier kaum noch
jemand jetzt gibt es ja trotz des teils
shutdowns in deutschland sogar eine
zunahme der fälle kann sich denn die
politik wirklich erklären welche gründe
dafür verantwortlich sind
nun es gibt zumindest eine ganze reihe
von erklärungen die genannt werden ganz
wesentlich und das hat ja heute auch der
lkw chef betont die verringerung der
kontakte reicht noch nicht aus
schulen und kitas werden ja bewusst
offen gehalten im arbeitsleben ist die
home office quote noch zu gering aber
auch beispielsweise den einkaufszentren
treffen viel zu große ansammlung von
käufern zu nahe aufeinander
insgesamt fällt oft das stichwort
ermüdungserscheinungen das heißt dass
die menschen jetzt nach einem
dreivierteljahr der sozialen
beschränkungen ist auch laut sein und
sich nicht mehr ganz so diszipliniert
verhalten wie das in der ersten welle
der pandemie noch der fall war
die gol vielen dank für diese
einschätzung heute abend über eine
stärkere beschränkung von kontakten
reden das heißt auch wir haben gerade
schon kurz angesprochen die schulen
deutlich stärker ins blickfeld nehmen
es gibt immer mehr forderungen jetzt wie
im frühjahr auf distanz unterricht zu
setzen
sachsen schließt die schulen bereits am
montag
und noch ein plan liegt auf dem tisch
frühere weihnachtsferien damit kinder
und jugendliche über die feiertage keine
verwandten anstecken anna du da jetzt
mit mehr dazu
die 710 präsenzunterricht am wilhelm von
humboldt gymnasium in ludwigshafen wo
der inzidenz wert bei 422 liegt
präsenzunterricht ist ganz sicher das
was wir bevorzugen
aber irgendwann haben wir uns dann
gefragt eben bei zunehmenden incidents
werden
was muss passieren dass ich irgendwie
was ändert lehrer und schüler plädieren
für eine verlängerung der
weihnachtsferien
ob nach hinten oder nach vorne nach
vorne ebenso weit dass sich menschen die
ihre familie gerne sehen würden kinder
die ihre omas und opas gerne sehen
würden
in quarantäne begeben könnten selbst
quarantäne um eben gewährleisten zu
können dass sie ihre verwandten an
weihnachten schützen in sachsen machen
schulen und kitas am montag zu in
mecklenburg vorpommern teilweise die
lehrervertreter sind enttäuscht dass die
bundesländer so lange an
präsenzunterricht festhielten
sie hätten viel früher auf die
forderungen des rk ii eingehen müssen
und zum wechsel unterricht übergehen
sollen
dann hätte man das vermeiden können was
jetzt geschehen muss und in sachsen
schon geschehen ist schulschließung doch
geschlossene schulen können bedeuten
bildungs verluste und soziale nachteile
für die kinder
es ist ganz wichtig alles daran zu
setzen dass die schülerinnen und schüler
weiter unterrichtet werden egal ob zu
hause oder im klassen kontext auf jeden
fall unterrichten und nicht ferien und
freizeit vorgehen doch eltern wollen
verhindern dass das unterrichten auf sie
abgeladen wird
deswegen fordern wir vor allen dingen
mehr personal gut ausgebildetes personal
um kleine klassen bilden zu können
um die klassen zu teilen
zur stunde beraten die kultusministerin
und minister die es für die schulen bis
und nach weihnachten weitergeht
ja und wir bewerten die deutschen die
aktuelle corona lage das zdf
politbarometer zeigt sie machen sich
sorgen immer mehr mittlerweile 60
prozent der befragten sehen ihre
gesundheit durch das virus gefährdet und
etwa jeder zweite meint dass die
bisherigen beschränkungen nicht
ausreichen da wird sauer hat die details
gastronomie kultureinrichtungen
fitnessstudios alles dicht
einschränkungen die sich bislang aber
nicht auszahlen
die infektions kurve geht hoch die
akzeptanz der maßnahmen sinkt nur noch
35 prozent finden die aktuellen
vorschriften richtig 49 prozent sagen
sie gehen nicht weit genug
seit beginn der korona krise hat eine
mehrheit der deutschen die jeweils
geltenden maßnahmen stets für gerade
richtig befunden jetzt ist das anders
die zustimmung sinkt drastisch die
pandemie noch nicht im griff trotzdem
soll weihnachten mit der ganzen familie
erlaubt sein
lockerungen an weihnachten hält rund
jeder zweite für falsch lockerungen an
silvester lehnen sogar 79 prozent ab und
wenn die aktuellen corona maßnahmen
nicht greifen will eine große mehrheit
den kompletten shutdown das pandemie a
2020 war für die meisten menschen
unerwartet entbehrungsreich entsprechend
durchwachsen ist die bilanz seit der
wiedervereinigung ist die persönliche
jahresbilanz der deutschen doch nie so
kritisch ausgefallen selbst die finanz
und wirtschaftskrise hat keine
derartigen spuren hinterlassen
fast die hälfte zieht ein schlechtes
fazit 45 prozent doch es gibt auch
optimismus viele glauben 2021 wird
besser das ist schlechter wird hält kaum
jemand für möglich und das komplette
politbarometer nachher im heute journal
um kurz vor zehn und schon jetzt in der
zdf- heute- app alle zahlen und grafiken
zum durchklicken
ganz hart greift jetzt frankreich durch
im kampf gegen die hohen
infektionszahlen die regierung verhängte
für silvester eine nächtliche
ausgangssperre von 20 uhr bis 7 uhr
morgens
damit dürfen die franzosen den
jahreswechsel nicht im freien feiern
und jetzt in der sendung schauen wir auf
die europäische union von der können
besonders von der pandemie betroffene
länder jetzt endlich auf hilfe hoffen
vor wenigen minuten die nachricht nach
monatelangem gezerre gibt es einen
kompromiss im haushaltsstreit im juli
hatten die mitgliedsländer ein 1,8
billionen euro paket geschnürt 750
milliarden für den corona wiederaufbau
von plus der eu haushalt für die
nächsten sieben jahre in höhe von 1.000
74 milliarden
außerdem wurde vereinbart dass es
künftig immer nur dann geld geben soll
wenn ein mitgliedsland rechtsstaatliche
standards einhält
deshalb hatten polen und ungarn das
paket blockiert wie die lösung jetzt
aussieht zeigt stefan leifert als die
kanzlerin erscheint liegt die härteste
verhandlung schon hinter ihr im letzten
anlauf den erbitterten streit um
haushalt und rechtsstaatlichkeit zu
lösen gelang der ratspräsidentschaft ein
kompromiss mit ungarn und polen von dem
merkel jetzt noch den gipfel überzeugen
muss wir haben jedenfalls versucht viele
vorarbeiten zu leisten und es wäre
natürlich ein sehr wichtiges zeichen
auch für die handlungsfähigkeit der
europäischen union wenn wir dieses
wichtige ergebnis erzielen könnten
viktor orban und polens premierminister
morawski drohten bis zu letzt
eu-haushalt und corona hilfen zu
blockieren komme die eu ihnen nicht
entgegen
der neue rechtsstaatlichkeit mechanismus
sieht nun vor dass die eu mittel kürzen
darf wenn länder gegen
rechtsstaatlichkeit verstoßen ernten
kann sie aber nur verstöße die direkt
gelder des eu-haushalts betreffen also
vor allem korruption in kraft treten
soll alles erst nach einem urteil
frühestens 2022
wir müssen verhindern dass es zu
beliebigen und zu politisch motivierten
entscheidungen kommt deswegen haben wir
so lange diskutiert den ziel ganz
präzise schlussfolgerungen auszuarbeiten
polen und ungarn feiern den kompromiss
wie einen sieg wenn er durchgeht wäre
der weg frei für
1,8 millionen euro eu haushalt und
corona hessen
wir sind ganz ganz kurz davor einen sehr
guten kompromiss zu erzielen der auch
für die einigkeit der eu gut ist wir
kämpfen also heute auch für den
zusammenhalt unseres kontinents
rechtsstaatlichkeit mechanismus ist ein
großes wort für ein kleines instrument
aber immerhin
die eu scheint den großen eklat gerade
noch abgewendet zu haben
wenn er durch geht hat der kollege da
gerade gesagt wir können sagen jetzt ist
es soweit er ist durchgegangen die
einigung im haushaltsstreit ist da und
dann geht es auf dem gipfel um das
klimaziel der eu für 2030 co2 emissionen
runter und mindestens 55 prozent an der
gallinat live in brüssel gibt es denn da
für ein grünes licht
die diskussionen laufen noch aber die
aussichten sind nicht so schlecht die eu
will im jahr 2050 klimaneutral sein und
um das zu schaffen braucht sie jetzt
ehrgeizige zwischenziele so ein
verschärfter vorschlag liegt jetzt auf
dem gipfel tisch die eu-mitgliedstaaten
sollen bis 2030 55 mindestens 55 prozent
co2 emissionen einsparen
darüber hatte es vor einem jahr noch
einen dicken streit besonders mit polen
gegeben deren dessen wirtschaft noch
ziemlich stark von der kohle ab hängt
jetzt also können sich alle dahinter
versammeln natürlich gibt es
diskussionen darüber wie viel geld die
osteuropäischen länder für den umbau von
kohle zu anderen energieträgern aus
brüssel erwarten können und ob
vielleicht kernkraft auch so eine
alternative energie sein könnte fazit
den das ziel hinter dem ziel können sich
alle vereinigen der weg dahin ist noch
strittig
vielen dank auch die europäische
zentralbank nimmt noch mal sehr viel
geld in die hand um die wirtschaftlichen
folgen der krise abzufedern ezb chefin
christine lagarde bekannt weitere staats
und unternehmensanleihen zu kaufen
dafür investiert die bank 500 milliarden
euro zusätzlich und weitet ihr programm
damit auf 1,85 billionen euro auslaufen
sollen die anleihenkäufe nun mindestens
bis ende märz 2022
270 millionen menschen sind vom
hungertod bedroht und durch die korona
pandemie ist die lage noch schlimmer
geworden
das sind mahnende worte heute vom chef
des welternährungsprogramms der
vereinten nationen david beasley als er
für seine organisation den
friedensnobelpreis entgegennimmt
die organisation kämpft weltweit für
hunderte millionen menschen die hunger
leiden kriege und klimawandel
verschärften das problem außerdem werde
hunger als politische und militärische
waffe genutzt
facebook ist das weltweit größte
internetnetzwerk gehört zum alltag von
milliarden
facebook ist auch ein hort von falschen
informationen hass und verschwörungs
geschichten und facebook ist reich und
mächtig jetzt gerät der konzern unter
druck sowie vermutlich noch nie in
seiner fast 17 jährigen geschichte
die amerikanische kartellbehörde und
fast alle us bundesstaaten wollen die
marktmacht von facebook mit hilfe von
gerichten brechen
der konzern soll whatsapp und instagram
verkaufen peter theisen mit mir daumen
runter für facebook die oberste
kartellbehörde der usa wirft dem
sozialen netzwerk unfairen wettbewerb
vor und zieht mit mehr als 40
bundesstaaten gegen facebook vor gericht
das ziel nichts weniger als die
zerschlagung des internetriesen seit
fast einem jahrzehnt nutzt facebook
seine beherrschen der monopolstellung um
kleinere rivalen zu vernichten und
wettbewerb auszulöschen
und das alles auf kosten derer die
facebook tag für tag nutzen
konkret kritisiert die behörde dass
facebook in den letzten jahren immer
wieder konkurrenten aufkaufte und sich
so eine monopolstellung verschaffte so
übernahm facebook etwa den fotodienst
instagram und den chat-dienst whatsapp
doch auch viele kleinere rivalen seien
bedroht oder aufgekauft worden so
kritiker sie agieren vielleicht clever
aber wettbewerbswidrig illegal
sie versuchen sich als mitbewerber auf
aggressive weise auszuradieren damit sie
keine konkurrenz mehr haben
facebook gründer mark zuckerberg weist
darauf hin dass die kartellbehörde die
übernahme damals jahr genehmigt habe und
schreibt in einer internen botschaft an
die mitarbeiter
insgesamt sind wir mit den vorwürfen der
regierung nicht einverstanden und planen
dagegen vor gericht zu kämpfen
die realität ist dass wir bei allem was
wir machen mit vielen anderen diensten
konkurrieren und zwar fair facebook
unter beschuss das unternehmen wird sich
wohl verändern müssen doch es wird
vermutlich jahre dauern bis das
verfahren abgeschlossen ist und dann
heute die spektakuläre explosion einer
rakete die der besitzer spacex gründer
elon musk erstaunlich locker nimmt eine
unbemannte testrakete von spacex ist
beim landeanflug in texas in flammen
aufgegangen sie war zu schnell
elon musk nannte die mission trotzdem
ein erfolg man habe alle notwendigen
daten sammeln können irgendwann sollen
solche raketen zum mars fliegen
das ist zukunft die realität ist erst
einmal der sport katja los geht's mit
fußball in der fußball-champions-league
gibt es aus deutscher sicht in dieser
woche nur gute nachrichten auch gestern
wieder die bayern gewinnen 2 0 gegen
lokomotive moskau und auch die
gladbacher sind im freudentaumel
denn sie stehen im achtelfinale trotz 0
2 niederlage gegen real madrid aber dank
schützenhilfe gewonnen aber erst nach
spielende grenzenloser jubel über das
null zu null beim parallelspiel in
mailand das den gladbachern doch den
einzug ins achtelfinale beschert wenn
sehr stolz auf die jungs ich glaube ein
besonderer moment für für den verein für
unsere fans über den wir uns sehr freuen
gladbach chancenlos im trainings stadion
von madrid benzema trifft zwei mal für
real das mit trainer sie dann ebenfalls
weiter kommt
aber nur die gladbacher feiern fiesta in
madrid italien trauert um einen seiner
größten fußballer paolo rossi ist im
alter von nur 64 jahren gestorben
im wm finale 1982 in madrid traf rossi
zum 1 0 gegen deutschland italien gewann
am ende 3 2 1 und wurde weltmeister und
rossi im gleichen jahr auch noch europas
fußballer des jahres
am wochenende werden in planica
slowenien wm medaillen im skifliegen
vergeben und zu den titel favoriten in
der einzelwertung gehört ganz klar auch
markus eisenbichler warum zu recht hat
er heute eindrucksvoll in der
qualifikation bewiesen
die form stimmt die weiter am ende auch
225 anhalt meter flug markus
eisenbichler bei ungünstigem wind mit
guten haltungsnoten gewann der deutsche
die quali der skiflug-wm jetzt will er
nach dem wm titel greifen denn
zweitbester deutscher war karl geiger
mit 228 meter
die tagesbestweite von 242 5 meter flog
der österreicher michael heimberg er
hatte eine lücke mehr anlauf und
besseren wind wurde am ende zweiter der
qualifikation
intersport morgen ab 11 15 uhr live im
zdf hat ja danke an diesem besonderen
tag heute von uns allen herzlichen
glückwunsch
und noch was zu feiern die juden in
aller welt feiern
hallo k das lichterfest acht tage lang
wie in vielen städten der welt steht
seit heute auch vor dem brandenburger
tor in berlin wieder ein riesiger
hannover leuchter
mit einbruch der dunkelheit wird
feierlich das erste licht entzündet und
bis zum 18 dezember von jeden abend eine
weitere kerze hinzu kam luca ist ein
fest mitsingen und feiern im
familienkreis dieses jahr aber natürlich
leider mit vielen einschränkungen axa
mehr das wetter wenig festlich für viele
trüb für manche auch gefährlich glatt
nur ein bisschen sonne details gleich
von katja ohne war das heute schon mit
der kollegin marietta slomka kurz vor 10
heute und jetzt gleich nach uns das zdf
spezial wann kommt der harte shutdown
danke fürs zuschauen bis morgen und in
allen einen sehr angenehmer
[Musik]
knaben meine damen und herren den
vergangenen tagen gab es ja rekord
neuschneemengen in den alpen das wird
jetzt erst mal nicht mehr der fall sein
denn es beruhigt sich in den alpen
jedenfalls vorübergehend
heute war es ja fast überall bedeckt in
deutschland nur im äußersten westen
da machte sich eine wolkenlücken über
frankreich bemerkbar und von frankreich
wird jetzt auch milder morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen in großbritannien und
frankreich zwischen 7 und 15 grad über
aus europa ist es noch deutlich kühler
mit meist nur so 0 bis 5 grad bei uns
sinken die temperaturen über schnee an
den alpen heute bis -8 grad deutlich
milder bleibt die nacht auf norderney
mit zwei grad in schleswig holstein kann
es noch etwas schnee oder regen geben
sonst bildet sich auch mal liebl und im
südwesten ist es zunächst noch klar
das ändert sich am vormittag da beginnt
es nämlich mit gefährlichem schnee
schneeregen und glatteisregen ganz
anders sieht es an den alpen aus da wird
doch nicht und am nachmittag sogar noch
sonniger derweil die glatteis
regenwolken weiter nach osten ziehen das
sauerland erreichen und zum abend auch
die schwäbische alb der wind dazu kommt
aus südöstlichen richtungen unsere
steigen die temperaturen morgen des 6
grad in der lausitz und am oberrhein und
in den nächsten tagen wird es von tag zu
tag ein bisschen bilder schönen abend
noch